why she hasn't seen the project yet
Martin Sheen is reacting to OJ Simpson
prosecutor Marcia Clark's new Today Show
interview where she calls his new OJ
Simpson docu-series quote nonsense
I actually know the theory and what
they're basing it on and it's nonsense
yeah there's nothing to it there is no
real logic there's no evidence there's
nothing to back it up
nothing Marcia Clark recently came out
criticizing your project Oh Jay is
innocent how do you respond to that I
would reserve judgment we're just asking
a few questions about the original trial
and there's a lot of information and a
lot of evidence that has never been
uncovered before so we're just going to
present some questions pertaining to the
the evidence and see where it lies
that's all you know I'm not challenging
her and she ought not to make a judgment
without seeing the series Martin got
candid with et at Thursday's we Day
event in Los Angeles well this is a
celebration of all of these
extraordinary young people who have
dared to step out and challenge their
peers to serve others it's celebrating
what they've done and they're here and
to encourage them and they encourage
each other to go out and continue to
change the changing world
you know it's theirs they are the future